cbs news legal analyst ricky clement is
here to sort this all out for us uh
ricky it's
i'm glad you're here because all i keep
thinking about are these four families
who have lost children and when you
think that there appear to be so many
warning signs here so many red flags at
the very least it's very rare for
parents to be charged but this feels
very different it does feel different
and the prosecutor made us know why it
felt different because of the egregious
actions according to the prosecutor of
these defendants these parents are they
sending a message do you think well i
think that the prosecutor is definitely
sending a message not only to other
parents about watching your children
seeing if they have any
issues that really need looking into but
it's the prosecutor is also sending a
message to parents about securing guns
and most important sending a message to
other prosecutors if not now when
i've been covering these cases since
columbine in 1999
school shooting after school shooting so
it's time
and this may be the type of case because
of these text messages because of the
school
contacting the parents and the parents
not responding does make me wonder why
nobody looked in the backpack now we
know the parents knew that he had a gun
certainly or access to a gun the school
might not have known but it does make me
wonder why didn't anybody search him
before he went into class well you're
looking at liability criminally now on
the part of the parents then the
question becomes will there be liability
likely civil liability on the part of
the school
so what duty did each of these groups
have if the parents know that they
bought a gun and they may know that they
didn't secure it the child has a
backpack why wouldn't you look the
school may not have known the school
needs reasonable suspicion in order to
look in that backpack the school said
that this this kid had no disciplinary
problems he said he was a video gamer
working on a video game plan note to
self to take that with a grain of salt
maybe in the future the parents defense
attorneys say look they weren't planning
to flee they were just trying to sort it
out yet they're found with four thousand
dollars in cash in an abandoned
warehouse building what do they need to
sort out and if it's believed that
they're trying to flee how does that
impact their case flight is very bad for
these parents because it's called
consciousness of guilt it becomes
admissible at a trial as an element of
guilt the flight may be the worst thing
in terms of the evidence at trial
against these parents in addition to
their own behavior all right i take it
you agree that the parent should have
been charged here i think if not now
when it's about time yeah thank you
ricky clayman
nate
necessary conversation president biden
plans to speak with russian and russian
president vladimir putin tomorrow as
tensions rise